bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filcho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette émission dans l'actualité de
cette semaine le groupe égis signe un
partenariat avec l'Université de
Saint-Quentin en iveline le monde de
l'entreprise se rapproche du milieu
universitaire nous verrons le bilan
touristique de cet été dans les ivlines
les Jardins de Cocagne à manilamo font
appel au financement
participatif l'entreprise de la semaine
c'est fbots située à voisin le
Bretonneux elle fait partie des Laura du
prix Paris saint-clay invest enfin zoom
sur un métier celui d'artisan boucher un
secteur qui recrute et puis nous
parlerons de la rentrée économique et de
l'Université du mdeef qui a eu lieu à
joui en Josas nous retrouverons bertr
decé vous êtes le président du MDEF des
Yvelines monur bonjour Nous reviendrons
avec vous sur la situation économique
actuelle mais avant cela place aux
information économique de la
semaine la conception de la prochaine
Blue Car 3 plac se fera au technocentre
de Renault situé à Guill encour la Blue
Car c'est la voiture électrique utilisé
pour le concept d'autopartage loué dans
le cadre d'autolb à Paris les groupes
Renault et Boloré ont enteriné mardi
dernier un partenariat concernant ces
véhicules électriques le modèle sera
ensuite produit à Dieb dès le 2 semestre
2015 il est prévu également la création
d'une coentreprise détenue à 70 % par
Boloré et à 30 % par Renault dans
l'autopartage pour rappel le système
d'autolibbe a été lancé fin 2011 il
exploite aujourd'hui plus de 2500 blue
carar et plus de 5000 points de recharge
à Paris et en banlieu parisienne
l'objectif du groupe Boloré est de
disposer de 3000 véhicules en
circulation fin 2014 puis 4000 en
2015 un partenariat a été signé
aujourd'hui entre le groupe égis et
l'Université de saint-quenttin en
Yveline l'objectif est de rapprocher ces
deux ces deux entités et de faciliter
les contacts l'accord cadre qui a été
signé avec le département universitaire
de droit juridique prévoit la mise en
place de conférences pour les étudiants
une politique d'accueil des doctorants
va également être mené et des stages de
fin d'études seront proposés aux
étudiants de Master
2 monsieur ce sont l'étudis à qui on
aura montré concrètement le monde de
l'entreprise et puis bah ils nous
aideront à à traiter nos nos problèmes
nos problèmes juridiques et on espère
que bah voilà ils seront intéressés à
poursuivre une carrière chez nous ou
ailleurs dans des à proximité de
d'ingénieurs donc de métiers technique
et que la technique et le droit se
rencontrre bien il y a un point très
important qui est le développement de ce
que nous appelons les conventions
ciffres qui sont des bourses de doctorat
et qui permettent aux étudiants de faire
ce qu' l'on appelle des tests
professionnels c'est-à-dire de faire une
thèse pour devenir docteur de
l'université et en même temps de faire
cette tèse en entreprise avec un
financement de l'entreprise dans
l'objectif de servir au mieux les
intérêts de
l'entreprise l'été 2014 jugé plutôt
morose par les professionnels du
tourisme en Île-de-France le bilan
économique des activités touristiques
est mitigé on note une baisse de 1 % de
la de la fréquentation pardon du Grand
Paris et de ses alentours alors entre
crise économique et météo capricieuse
quelles ont été les conséquences pour le
secteur du tourisme dans les
Yvelines pas de traitement de faveur
dans les ivelines les professionnels du
tourisme ont comme partout en France
subit les aléas de la météo au mois de
juillet 57 % jugeaient bonne leur
activité il n'étaaiit plus que 30 % au
mois d'août les activités de plein air
ont été les premières touchées comme le
zoau de toiri pourtant troisème site
touristique
d'Île-de-France on a perdu 6 ou 7 % à
toiri cette année du fait de la météo en
juillet et en aût globalement il y a un
palier cette année voir une petite
baisse cette année même constat à la
base de loisirs de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline avec seulement 17000 entrées
enregistrées pour la piscine availle
c'est 50 % d'entré en moins qu'en 2013
sur le mois de juillet août juillet-
août c'est 58 jours on est à la moitié
de moins que l'année dernière sur ces de
mois sur ces de mois sur les entrées du
parc on est à peu près à un petit peu
moins aujourd'hui mais il faut qu'
encore qu'on qu'on affine ces chiffres
on est un peu moins de 4 100000
visiteurs depuis le début de l'année à
savoir que l'année dernière au même
moment on était à 420 cet été les C
indor et les musées ont été privilégié
au mois de juillet 800000 touristes ont
visité le château de Versailles et le
Trianon avec une clientèle surtout
étrangère le domaine a logiquement vu sa
fréquentation augmenté de 2 %. la
clientèle d'affaires reste une valeur
sûre pour l'hôtellerie yvelinoise
habituellement moins sollicité en
période estivale si elle n'a pas subi de
baisse globale par rapport à l'année
dernière avec un taux d'occupation de 70
% au mois de juin 67 % en juillet et 57
% en août certaines catégories d'hôtel
rencontre des
difficultés sur l'aspect hôtellerie on
assiste à des difficultés pour les 4
étoiles puisque il y a plus de séminaire
qui se ment en place tout est tout est
fermé au mois d'août donc là les quatre
étoiles ont subi de plein fouet la la
crise la saison n'est pas encore finie
les professionnels ne sont pas inquiets
depuis depuis 4 ans la fréquentation ne
cesse d'augmenter sur les sites
touristiques et de loisirs dans les
ilines à manie Lamo l'Association des
Jardins de Cocagne voit ses subventions
diminuer elle a décidé de faire appel au
site internet KissKiss bbank cette
plateforme de financement participatif
qui aide les particuliers à collecter
des fonds pour réaliser des projets
l'objectif récolté assez d'argent pour
acheter du matériel et continuer à
cultiver dans de bonnes conditions des
images de Patrick Jacques de de Dixmude
donc ça par exemple c'est mais vraiment
une ancienne moteuse bon elle est pas en
état de de
fonctionner avoir une nouvelle moteuse
une nécessité pour le jardin de Cocagne
en pleine saison il faut par exemple
10000 motes de mâche pour fournir les
paniers de légumes vendu chaque mois par
l'association d'insertion sans l'aide du
Conseil général les subventions ont
diminué de 20 % soit 60000 € en moins
dans ces conditions difficile de
racheter du matériel ça va être beaucoup
plus difficile euh à faire parce que en
fait quand les modes sortent elles sont
déjà prêtes on a plus qu'à semer donc
c'est et euh sans la moteuse honnêtement
je ne sais pas comment pour paller cette
difficulté l'association a décidé de
faire appel au site internet de
financement participatif KissKiss bankb
habituellement destiné à financer des
projets culturels des documentaires ou
aider des start-ups ce recours est
inhabituel pour l'association mais
nécessaire
les aid de l'État diminuent fortement et
donc on a beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui à
monter dossier même de subvention privé
donc c'est une nouvelle méthode qui est
aujourd'hui très à la mode le
financement participatif et cela
permetah d'avoir des fonds autrement et
nous faire connaître aussi actuellement
on est en standby complet pour faire nos
petites motes qui font nos plans à plus
tard donc c'est une période assez creuse
actuellement donc ça va c'est tant mieux
par contre à partir du mois d'octobre il
faudra absolument qu'on recommence les
mes le jardin de manilamo espère obtenir
les 5000 € nécessaires à l'achat de sa
nouvelle moteuse pour l'instant le
projet a rassemblé plus de 1500 € il
prendra fin dans 40 jours date des
premières plantations de la
saison l'entretien de cette semaine
porte sur la rentrée économique Bertrand
de Cré bonjour et merci d'être venu sur
notre plateau alors vous êtes le
président du f des evelines je le
rappelle alors pour commencer
qu'avez-vous pensé du message fort
adressé par le Premier ministre manuel
Vals au chef d'entreprise et que cela
signifie-t-il alors je le rappelle
c'était fin août à l'université du mdeef
à jouillant Josas Quentin Premier
ministre de la France nous dit j'aime
l'entreprise eux n n l'ont pas bouser
notre plaisir donc c'est clair il est
clair que c'est un message très positif
euh qui marque non pas un tournant parce
qu'il est dans la droite file du
discours du président de la République
de janvier euh qui lui met la droite
file du de la lettre de de de Pierre
gataz faite au président en novembre
2013 euh qu'en ai-je pensé
clairement ce sont des mots ce sont des
mots mais je préfère entendre ces
mots-là que d'autres plus agressifs B
quand on dit je vous aime ben j'ai
tendance à vouloir y croire euh bien
entendu euh il faudra des actes euh et
je suis de ceux qui veulent y croire je
suis pas naïf mais je vous le dis je
suis optimiste et je veux y croire alors
une des mesures phar du gouvernement et
le cice pierre gataz le président à la
tête du meddef s'est dit plutôt
satisfait donc de ce crédit d'impôt pour
la compétitivité et l'emploi 2 ans après
son annonce pensez-vous que cela puisse
réellement aider les entreprises en
difficulté et est-ce que vous-même vous
en avez bénéficié alors ça la première
question est-ce que ça peut aider oui
toutes les baisses de charg des
entreprises aideront les entreprises
puisque c'est de l'argent qu' ne dépense
pas dans des charges c'est de l'argent
qu'ils ont avoir de disponible soit pour
de l'emploi soit pour de
l'investissement euh donc c'est une
bonne mesure et toutes les mesures qui
contribueront à faire baisser nos
charges sont des bonnes mesures la
deuxème question c'est à titre personnel
enfin personnel dans mon entreprise
effectivement le cice euh j'en ai j'en
ai touché ENF je vais en toucher par
c'est un crédit d'impôt euh et très
clairement alors est-ce que c'est ce qui
m'a décidé à investir j'ai j'ai j'ai
fait un investissement important
l'aurais-je fait sans cela peut-être pas
c'est c'est pas ce qui a décidé
réellement mais c'est ce qui m'a incité
à le faire voyez et je pense que nous
sommes nombreux en tant che entreprise
qui hésitions parce que face à la
morosité du climat face à la
certitude que nous avons quelquefois
nous hésitons et le cice est
certainement un facteur de d'aide euh
donc c'est une mesure très positive euh
il a été également question du pacte de
responsabilité et de solidarité qui vise
à baisser le le coût du travail en
France il a été bien accueilli par les
chefs d'entreprise moins par les
syndicats en quoi cela peut-il aider à à
dynamiser pardon l'économie du
département bien alors du département g
du territoire français dans son ensemble
euh
aujourd'hui il faut comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui plus ns entreprise et et
ont de charg moins elles ont de
ressources disponibles ce que je vous
disais
euh nous ne réclamons un alignement sur
la fiscalité européenne c'est tout
simplement ce que nous demandons le PACT
de c'est quoi c'est d'arriver à faire
quel chose de gagnant gagnant gagnant
l'entreprise qui va avoir ses charges
baissées va pouvoir investir cet argent
créer des emplois et ce sera gagnant
gagnant il faut sortir du du
dogme ce que je vous disais aujourd'hui
j'entends quelquefois alors dans la
bouche de syndicat dans la bouche
quelquefis le journaliste euh on parle
de cadeau fait au patron un cadeau fait
à l'entreprise c'est un cadeau fait au
patron mais c'est une inepsie un cadeau
fait un entreprise c'est un cadeau fait
la collectivité en France et notre par
n'y échappe pas 94 ou 96 % des
entreprises ont moins de 10 salariés
elles ont souvent été créées par
d'anciens salariés et lors les hommes
qui sont et les femmes qui sont à leur
tête n'ont qu'une envie c'est développer
leur entreprise on est là pour on a des
projets qu'on fait participer à au
salariés qu'on veut développer et tout
ce qui nous permet d'avoir tous les
moyens que nous pourrons investir dans
développement nous le ferons donc c'est
positif pour tout le
monde quelles sont selon vous les
préoccupations des chefs d'entreprise de
notre
département de de notre département et
je dirais
français leur préoccupation c'est
l'avenir c'est ce que un entrepreneur
c'est quelqu'un qui qui doit voir loin
qui doit prendre des décisions qui
auront des impacts pour de dans un an
dans 3 ans dans 4 ans donc nous avons
besoin de confiance et de stabilité
c'est c'est aussi ce que prêche le MDF
par la bouche de Pierre gataz c'est de
grâce messieurs les politiques
donnez-nous un environnement législatif
et fiscal stable comprenez quand on
prévoit un investissement lourd qui qui
n'aura une que sur plusieurs années si
on change tout le système entre temps
qu' dé tricote on peut arriver
complètement à laavers de ce qu'on
voulait au départ donc les G ce qu'ils
veulent c'est de la stabilité ce qu'il
veulent la stabilité en terme fiscal
social
législatif très bien et bien tout de
suite nous allons passer à la question
de la
semaine on a on a déjà aujourd'hui
suffisamment de de cassur entre les les
différents les différents milieux
sociaux français pour ne ne pas en
rajouter qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire la
situation est pas facile bon
je suis pas d'accord mais comment faire
autrement rien de bon c'est déjà
horriblement cher
donc encore un retrait dans la dans la
caisse c'est associé à tellement d'autre
mesure qui vont dans un sens différent
je peux pas comprendre qu'on la fe
maintenant on fallait la faire à
l'époque où Sarkozi il avait desciidé
c'est toujours une très mauvaise idée la
TVA bah tout le monde la paye et c'est
quelque chose qui est très juste parce
que tout le monde la paye mais en même
temps ça pénalise beaucoup les gens qui
sont à faible faible ressource et les
autres aussi
d'ailleurs alors justement sur cette
question de de la TVA est-ce que vous
vous avez une une réaction par rapport à
ça rapidement c'est un sujet très
compliqué très compliqué parce que
euh nous sommes en crise on a un état
dont on sait dont les caisses sont
quasiment vides il faut les
remplir je disais tout à l'heure que les
entreprises sont un taux de saturation
au niveau de leur charge donc leur
remettre une couche il faut plus en
enlever qu'en remettre maintenant il
faut argent euh alors la TVA pourrait
sembler plus dis bien pourrait sembler
une bonne idée au sens où elle Estelle
elle a l'air juste en pant sur
l'ensemble de la population euh
toutefois une une des intervenants le
disait
euh recharger et et baisser le pouvoir
d'achat des populations les plus faibles
et pas forcément une très bonne idée
donc c'est je serais très circonspect
entre bien ou mal alors peut-être un
ajustement et peut-être pas forcément
toute la TVA je pense les prod
nécessités des produits alimentaires ne
pas toucher au TVA pourquoi pas la
mettre sur certains autres produits mais
bon je c'est une question qui qui
appelle beaucoup de réflexion c'est une
question effectivement qui mérite
réflexion et bien au revoir monsieur
Bertron de CR et merci d'être venu sur
notre plateau tout de suite le chiffre
de la
semaine le chiffre de la semaine
concerne le chômage dans les ivelines
6,6 c'est le pourcentage de personnes
qui viennent s'ajouter au demandeurs
d'emploi dans le département toute
catégorie confondu selon pô emploi
85060 demandeur d'emploi été recensé en
juin 2014 ils sont aujourd'hui
85560 on constate donc une hausse de 6,6
% en un an en comparaison
l'Île-de-France a également enregistré
une hausse sur ce chiffre 6,5 % pour la
même
période
fbots est une jeune micro-entreprise
située à voisin le breteneux elle est
spécialisée dans les solutions robotique
pour le nettoyage industriel alors elle
a été sélectionnée parmi les lauréa 2014
pour le prix Paris sac invest qui qui
récompense pardon les jeunes entreprises
car même pour des secteurs pourtant
dynamiques et novateurs comme la
robotique les premiers pas ne sont pas
si faciles William l et Romain
rpin
donc le centre d'attion depuis 4 ans le
F robot est un robot destiné à nettoyer
des surfaces de 15000 à 30000 m² si son
homologue domestique est bien connu du
grand public il existe peu d'offres à
destination des
professionnels donc là il est dans un
mode où il essaie de suivre le mur au
plus proche de façon à bien nettoyer le
bas des palettes sont des parties où les
poussières
s'accumulent et n'a rien à faire il se
débrouille absolument tout seul à
l'origine de cette aventure deux
ingénieurs installés à voisin le
Bretonneux Bertrand mererou et Johann
devvulder ils se sont rencontrés il y a
18 ans lors de leurs études à Central
Marseille passionnés par les robots ils
ont ensemble participé chaque année à la
Coupe de France de Robotique avant de se
lancer et l'aventure est risquée une
entreprise sur deux ne survit pas plus
de 5 ans après sa création s'il y a des
points bloquants faut les
remonter et qu'on puisse même se réunir
voir comment on peut débloquer la
situation et queon reste pas chacun dans
notre coin on s'est dit dès le départ si
on va voir un banquier ou si on va voir
la B ou genre de chose alors qu'on a pas
d'activité ça va être très dur de
trouver des financements dès le départ
la création de fbot on dit qu'il y
aurait deux activités une qui e-commerce
qui allit vendre des produits toujours
dans le domaine de la robotique parce
que ça c'est vraiment le fil conducteur
de la société pour les particuliers et
en parallèle de cette activité on a
commencé à mettre en place la partie RD
commencer à travailler sur des projets
jusqu'au projet d'aujourd'hui être
autonome financièrement une nécessité
pour les deux entrepreneurs si au début
ils ont compter sur une aide de 30000 €
versée par la BPI ce n'est qu'au bout de
3 ans d'existence qu'ils ont pu
bénéficier de soutien supplémentaire
notamment d'un prêt à tau zéro de 300000
€ si mécaniquement on lui interdit
d'aller plus une position en
arrière plus les aides sont nombreuses
plus les contrôles financiers sont
importants alors pour garder du temps et
une certaine indépendance faibot a
commencé à se financer grâce à la Love
monnaie les proches la famille ou
l'entourage deviennent les investisseurs
avec cet actionnaire la société a pu
dégager les fonds nécessaires à son
projet les anthropologistiques peuvent
être très grand jusqu'à 60000 m car il
faut un robot qui est de l'intelligence
et qui repasse pas plein de fois au même
endroit et donc toute cette gestion de
trajectoire est vraiment une partie où
il y a énormément de recherche et
développement à faire donc pour nous
c'est un budget à peu près de l'ORD d'un
million d'euros de frais de
développement on est en attente de
fabrication du nouveau prototype et on
espère être prêt pour une
commercialisation vers la fin du premier
trimestre prochain le robot final
devrait être commercialisé autour des
40000 € et déjà de grandes entreprises
comme Carrefour ou Coca-Cola se montrent
intéressé aujourd'hui la valorisation de
la société est de 600000 € elle devrait
selon ses fondateurs se situer entre 10
et 20 millions d'euros d'ici 5
ans notre zoom de la semaine est est
consacré au métier de boucher c'est un
métier d'artisanat qui recrute environ 4
1000 personnes par an une profession qui
ne connaît pas le chômage mais qui
pourtant peine à employer nous avons
rencontré Philippe leuger Boucher à
Chevreuse pour en savoir un peu plus sur
son métier un sujet réalisé par Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud avec le su je voudrais deux
escalopes de Dan s'il vous
plaît comme Philippe ils sont 70000 en
France à travailler en boucherie en
supermarché ou en laboratoire industriel
le savoir-faire des artisans bouchés est
très demandé pourtant chaque année il
manque 450 apprentis rien qu'en région
parisienne le métier a du mal à séduire
le plus compliqué au début c'est de
toucher la matière première voilà si on
aime ce contact ça va tout seul après
après on va dire que faut être courageux
c'est par rapport au nombre d'heures on
va dire que malheureusement l'
apprentissage je crois qu'il a une
moyenne c'est c'est 6 sur 10 qui arrête
la boucherie après l'apprentissage qui
sont écuré dans les heures la formation
c'est 2 ans de d'apprentissage à la base
et puis après ben on rentre dans la vie
active directement on est toujours en
laboratoire au début pour préparer que
de la viande entre l'apprentissage et
passer à laavant il a quand même 4 5 ans
qui se passe à son entrée sur le marché
du travail un jeune boucher gagne en
moyenne 1750 € nets les premiers
salaires s'échelonnent entre le SMIC et
peuvent aller jusqu'à 2000 € la journée
commence toutt et le travail est
physique mais le métier évolue comme
l'explique Philippe il a tenu plusieurs
boucherie et travaille dans ce secteur
depuis 23 ans nos anciens vendaient
beaucoup de viande la travaillit pas que
nous maintenant par contre on en vend
beaucoup moins mais par contre la
clientèle est beaucoup plus exigeante il
faut que tout soit travaillé pour être
au petit soin les perspectives
d'évolution arrivent rapidement en fin
de carrière un artisan peut toucher
jusqu'à 6000 € net par mois créer ou
reprendre une affaire un Paris attractif
lorsqu'on connaît le chiffre d'affaires
moyen par boucherie environ 370000 €
dont 10 % de résultats nets
là vous avez une étuve pour faire cuire
donc on va faire cuire les tripes on
fait cuire le boudin blanc pour les
jeunes vaut mieux qu'ils apprennent
plutôt la cuisine maintenant il y aura
plus de demandes dans le traiteur qu'en
charcuterie l'engouement actuel pour la
gastronomie les métiers de bouche et le
bio participent à remettre au goût du
jour ce métier en 2013 les inscriptions
en CAP Boucher ont augmenté de 15
% n TER terminons cette émission par
l'agenda de la semaine la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de Versailles
Eveline met en place des réunions
d'information gratuites destiné aux
porteurs de projets qui souhaitent
reprendre une entreprise cela s'appelle
les matinées de reprise entreprise la
prochaine aura lieu vendredi 12
septembre de 9h30 à 11h30 au 23 avenues
de Versailles à Paris le mercredi 17
septembre un rendez-vous création sur le
thème de l'auto-entrepreneur est
organisé à la Maison de l'Entreprise de
sa-quanttin en iveline la la rencontre
pardon est gratuite elle aura lieu à la
médiathèque qui est François
truffau merci de nous avoir suivi je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour un autre numéro de filech
je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée